sports illustrated swimsuit model hunter
mcgrady the 27 year old california girl
is enjoying her time in the spotlight
breaking all kinds of beauty barriers
my gosh how does it feel to be a part of
you know si history the curviest model
ever to grace
those pages this year i felt i felt i
think probably my most
confident i've ever felt so how does the
supermodel keep her face looking healthy
and moisturized while shooting for hours
on sun-soaked beaches
well we teamed up with hunter and olay
to show you how
what are some products that you kind of
go to to make sure your skin is radiant
i use the wrinkle corrections and serum
and the retinol 24
facial moisturizer together and what
they do is they really
hydrate and renew your sun damaged skin
while you
sleep i always tell girls and
guys i mean my husband uses it if you're
in the sun you have to back it up with a
retinol
so you apply the retinol at night time
and make sure that this is clear when
you are using a retinol
you have to use an spf during the
daytime
all right henry where can we get these
products you could find these products
at retailers nationwide and
olay.com they're my holy grail
if i had to pick two items to bring to a
deserted island honey you'd be bringing
your serum and your retinol and maybe a
hubby
exactly i guess we'll see
[Music]